[Music]
so welcome to the advance session on
building a cloud native application from
scratch
I am Kavita Radhakrishna I'm a senior PM
on Google cloud working on the GCP
marketplace as well as kubernetes
applications and I'll be speaking with
camel-hair chana who is our partner
engineer also on Google cloud and who
helps us get our partners on board into
the GCP marketplace and yes I know our
names are hard to pronounce
that's how advanced the session is thank
you today we will cover the ways
kubernetes applications greatly improve
the developer experience for cloud
native projects we'll be doing a very
detailed demo of building an app from
scratch on anthos our new hybrid and
multi cloud platform and how GCP
marketplace offers open source and
commercial solutions that accelerate
your development you know when we think
about cloud native we think about cloud
native technologies that help
enterprises build and run scalable and
secure applications in the cloud
containers secure mesh you know micro
services declarative API is these all
exemplify this approach many of our
customers including many of you here
actually think about you know the way
they modernize their applications using
containers and so what we found is that
they would start with a few containers
and then they start to scale those
containers and then when these
containers scale they turn to kubernetes
as an orchestration engine due to its
ease of use portability and
manageability let's start with a quick
show of hands how many of you are using
container images today okay fantastic
and how many of you are using kubernetes
in production right now and it could be
you're either on Prem or in the cloud
great that's a great number of you so
then I'm going to assume that many of
you are familiar with Cory's
sources like pods persistent volumes and
services that help you get your
workloads on to kubernetes and you're
familiar with the workloads resources
like deployments replicas sets stateful
sets and daemon sets for you to manage
your stateless and stateful workloads
but then we asked our customers for
feedback as they were writing these
applications and they told us that it
was really hard to manage all of these
different concepts and stitch them
together and if you do manage to stitch
them together how do you know that it
will work and will it continue working
especially as the ecosystem is scaling
and changing so rapidly so we asked
ourselves what if there was a way for us
to standardize how we interact with
these apps without all of this
complexity and that's how kubernetes
apps were born what we did is we worked
with cig apps in the open-source
community on standardizing on a
application resource which is a custom
resource definition or a CRD that helps
define the core resources and the
workload resources in your app in your
kubernetes applications
this helps us package up these resources
as a single app packaging up as a single
app has multiple advantages you know
we're able to provide you then with
lifecycle management debugging
monitoring and even building out an
ecosystem of apps that we know will work
well together thereby making these
enterprise ready containerized solutions
we then went one step further we saw
that customers were using health charts
for the deployments of their engine of
these applications and so we went ahead
and added a deployer in the marketplace
in the GCP marketplace that really helps
you deploy these apps anywhere on Prem
or in the cloud and so we've now created
these kubernetes applications we
announced the beta last year and these
are available in the GCP marketplace
enterprise ready continue eyes solutions
with pre-built deployment templates we
also made history with this beta launch
we were the first public cloud that
could support commercial kubernetes apps
in the GCP marketplace
but today is actually really exciting
day because I'm announcing the general
availability of kubernetes applications
in the GCP marketplace the GCP
marketplace for those who may not know
is a online curation a catalog of
solutions that we offer to enterprises
they cannot just find and buy solutions
just like any other marketplace but it
also offers support for management and
deployment of these solutions we offer
multiple features within the GCP
marketplace one is we're one of the few
public clouds that offer really popular
open source solutions packaged up in
that in the marketplace so for instance
RabbitMQ which we will show in the demo
later on or Postgres sequel that was
also in the demo one google bill so it
doesn't matter what kind of solution
you're using in the marketplace whether
it's SAS or data sets or kubernetes apps
or VMs any enterprise that is working
with the GCP marketplace gets one single
bill at the end of the day and us
customers can just start to use you know
if you're a developer that's using this
you can just start to use these products
within the marketplace as well flexible
pricing we offer we know that developers
want to be able to have you know the
flexibility of being able to pay as you
go and so the ability for you to really
be able be flexible with your use but
also offering subscriptions for more
predictable usage so if you want to be
able to use this over a monthly or
annual subscriptions which is going to
be out in beta soon but in addition I
also want to announce some new features
as part of the general availability the
first is that these apps work with
anthos and we'll cover a little bit in
more detail what this means but it
really opens up the world for these
applications to be available run you
know build once run anywhere to be able
to be supported on hybrid as well as
multi cloud cloud agnostic metering what
this means is that we actually follow
the app regardless of where the app is
deployed so let's say you are deploying
on 2g see
be in oil into another cloud you will
still get metering so you can price and
know you know that your application has
been priced correctly we also offer
custom price metrics so for instance if
you're building a CI CDE application
then maybe you want to price on say the
number of builds or the number of
deployments but if you're now building a
database by a base solution then you can
cut you can customize your pricing just
on storage and so we're very flexible
about offering you those features and
the last managed updates which is out in
alpha now one of the top asks and so I'm
going to dig into that just a little bit
more you know we're introducing this
because our customers told us that it
was really painful for us you know for
users to be able to create these
applications and then push them out to
customers and they're not having a great
way to update with the feature updates
or even if you want to fix security
vulnerabilities but instead of just
doing upgrades
we've also added health checks so we do
auto rollback when there's auto triggers
that can really push up rollback to a
version that works and so your customers
are really protected from you know any
changes that you may not be able to
control
we've also added UI and CLI support in
the marketplace so you can push these
updates at any cadence that you want to
you've all seen a version of this slide
at one of your sessions today you know
until now but just wanted to call out
why this is such an important part of
the GCP marketplace strategy so anthos
really opens up the world for us to be
building apps that you know you build
once and run anywhere and so for us to
be able to support this in the
marketplace so we have third-party apps
that are in the marketplace today that
work with anthos and you can start to
use them and you'll see that in the demo
you know this vision has attracted many
enterprise partners to our ecosystem
here's just a quick look at some of
those partners you will recognize some
really familiar names you will also see
some really exciting startups but you
will also see some really popular open
source solutions
that google has packaged up and is
making available on the marketplace as
well these are also in multiple fields
and if you take a quick look you'll see
there across security database storage
and learn machine learning
logging monitoring networking and much
more
so really expanding to a base that meets
the needs of any enterprise and also
excited to say that many of these are
available on Prem today with anthos a
huge thank you to these partners they've
been working very closely and really
hard over the last few weeks to make
this moment possible you will sure you
will see some of these particular wraps
in the demo speaking of which let me
please invite Kamel up on the stage
[Applause]
by everyone I'm coming Sonia I'm a
partner engineer at Google which
practically means that I work with our
awesome partners to build some cool
products for GCP marketplace and today
I'm gonna show you a few tips and tricks
that I use in everyday work Kavita how
can I actually help you today that's a
great question you know we could have
built any application or used any use
case but we've picked a broad enterprise
use case that covers product and finance
and marketing but you can use this to
extrapolate to any use cases you might
have so before I start let me transform
myself with these glasses into a
business analyst and I'm now speaking to
my app developer so hey come on we need
to build a custom metrics collection app
that collects you know metrics streams
from all over the world and this data
cannot fail you know this is absolutely
critical data for our business and also
remember that the US team is on GCP but
the AMIA team is on another cloud okay
it's a very interesting Hughes case so
let's start with those multiple systems
that want to connect to to our
application we don't have full control
over them probably some of them are
going to use some special data format or
custom authentication mechanisms so we
could actually start with the REST API
the REST API can be managed by an API
gateway like Apogee and it will allow us
to easily integrate multiple systems
together you also mention that you want
to run our application in different
environments like different clouds so we
want our application to be portable and
have a callable ecosystem so let's start
with kubernetes kubernetes sells like a
like a great fit it can run anywhere on
a premise and on different clouds and
actually with Antos that you mentioned
we can take advantage of managing those
different kubernetes clusters from a
single point which is GCP so tell me
something more about those spikes in
traffic
yes so see the marketing team runs
campaigns and events constantly and so
sometimes they collect new customers
which can really make the data spike
dramatically okay so it means that our
application needs to be out of scalable
to dynamically react to to increasing
demands that we may see at the same time
we want to save money and whenever the
traffic goes down we want to have an
ability to scale down you also mentioned
that we don't want to lose any data
that's right so whenever we are scaling
or facing any spikes we probably want to
use a message broker a message broker
will actually process the incoming
requests and let the backend handle them
whenever it's possible you know a
message broker sounds like a great fit
but don't forget the CIO is really
concerned about the data and the
security of that data okay I wouldn't be
that that much worried about security we
can use Sto easier will be used for
increasing the security thanks to the
different configurations that we can use
at this at the same time we can actually
take advantage of different monitoring
capabilities of each do this all sounds
great but I needed this yesterday ok yes
always so let's try and see what we can
achieve in 25 minutes 25 minutes
that's insane combo please take it away
ok let's do it so we have a bunch of
technical requirements that you
mentioned so let's do a small system
design so we started with the REST API
so we have different clients that are
connecting to our system through a REST
API service it must be backed up by some
component that is able to handle some
logic here so we'll have a deployment
for our API by its nature it's extremely
scalable because it's stateless so let's
take advantage of that and attach a
horizontal pod out a scalar that can
take care of automated scaling up and
down at the same time we know that some
of the data needs to be persisted so we
have a separate deployment
will serve as our back-end and it has it
sound horizontal pod autoscaler because
by its nature it scales differently than
the stateless API so we want to we want
to take take independent configuration
here at the same time we want to have a
database where will persist the
information we don't want to any vendor
locking we want to have solutions that
will be able to run anywhere so in this
particular case I will take advantage of
GCP marketplace and installed an
application from their open source
version of Postgres is already available
at the same time we need to connect
those those to the front end and back
end together and we'll do it with a
message broker with RabbitMQ RabbitMQ is
also available on GCP marketplace and
let's take advantage of that at the same
time we need to have some configuration
that will be shirt across those two
components so it will be something like
pointing to a specific end point for
rabbit for paws grass will have some
secrets for for authentication to those
systems and this will be shirt at the
same time we want to have sto for
additional security and this is our
system ok so let's take a demo it's
gonna be life so we'll see how it works
but in the demo we're going to show the
full the full experience the full
journey that a developer needs to take
so we'll start with actually creating
new clusters or connecting existing ones
because this is a very common situation
at the same time we want to deploy some
applications from GCP marketplace to gk
on Prem or external cluster we'll take a
look at the code and we'll transform it
to container images at first and after
that we'll run a kubernetes application
on our external cluster and then we will
release a new build of that application
which is also a common situation and at
the end we'll take a look at East you
and you're saying you're gonna do all
this in 25 minutes yeah and the bits
tickle we'll see okay
so let's kick off the demo yeah like
let's kick off okay I think we are
already switched to my computer which
actually shows exactly the same screen
so yeah great it's true so we were back
so as I promised we'll start from
scratch so whenever you start from
scratch you might not have any
kubernetes cluster so what we can do we
can create a new cluster on the cloud
and gke UI which is the user interface
for kubernetes engine on Google Cloud
console it's a great way to to actually
start so probably some of you have
already tried it
so I'm not gonna spend here too much
time and will not wait for the cluster
to be created but let's take a look at a
few options that might be useful for our
production workloads so first of all I
would think about using a regional
cluster instead of zonal one okay thanks
to that I will get high availability and
I will get multiple class multiple
masters running for for my cluster and
all of them managed by Google here I can
also select to have multiple node pools
perfectly adapted to whatever my
application might need so I might have a
few pools actually in the same cluster
with different sizing but there are also
advanced options that I might actually
use so let's start with such like enable
master authorized networks which will
not allow external endpoints to connect
to our master instances then we could
take a look at star driver integration
which is awesome because all the logs
from our kubernetes cluster and all the
metrics may automatically land in stack
driver and by the way in GCP marketplace
our application or actually most of the
applications already expose some app
specific metrics that can be collected
by star driver or your own permit use
magic matrix system so if you are
already from
with Prometheus you can take advantage
of that and simply integrate our apps
with your server in addition to that we
have such atoms like east yo with a
single click we can install East Iran
the cluster and no outer provisioning is
also very interesting because we wanted
our system to be outer scalable so we
start with the workloads and we use
horizontal pod out of scalars to
actually scale up and down dynamically
but at the same time we might think
about scaling the nodes on which our
cluster operates so additional VM
instances might be created automatically
or even right sizing might happen so the
size of the of the individual VM
instances might change so you can really
design your entire cluster right here
from within the c1 yep it's so powerful
Thanks ok but this use case is not that
very interesting and I think everyone is
what is waiting for connecting external
clusters and by the way I already have
one so let's take advantage of that I
switch to my terminal because here I
have some connectivity with an external
cluster let's see if it actually works
so I will maybe get a list of notes from
that cluster and see if we have
connection yeah houston it works great
so we have two nodes that are created on
another cloud we would like to connect
that cluster to gke UI and start
managing that cluster here so I have a
magic comment that that is actually
coming to be available publicly very
soon and connect where is it it's hidden
somewhere ok connect yep I have it
straight here no not yet it's been oh
this is real yeah definitely as always
she won't connect
and yeah almost there almost there
so what you've done here is you've
created a cluster on another cloud and
which many of you may already have right
you're all you're already running
kubernetes on clusters that are not on
GCP and what Karl's gonna show us here
is you can have this running cluster
that you can then use to connect either
from the cluster using your terminal
connect it to GK or through G from GK
itself exactly this is what we are going
to do as always Network works so slowly
so once again I will take advantage of
that's a term that I have already
prepared I need a bunch of variables
probably here okay great and now maybe
connect once again connect mg quote at
first alpha she called alpha yes I got
it
it's back
live demos always happening and tell us
what was happening there yes sure
so actually at this time I'm installing
an additional agent to our kubernetes
cluster and it will allow gke to handle
that cluster from from GK UI so we'll
have live connection between those two
let's see it looks like our job
succeeded so let's come back to GK UI
and refresh the list of clusters and
yeah it's there awesome awesome what
what you did here was using the your
terminal to run commands that will help
you connect the cluster to gke now
you're able to see within from within
gke not just clusters that are running
on GCP but clusters are running on other
clouds exactly awesome and as you can
see the list of notes is exactly the
same as I had in my terminal just a
minute ago so let's move farther with
that configuration once we have this
external cluster connected here maybe we
could actually try to deploy an
application here okay so I move to the
application screen this is a nice list
of applications that are installed to my
cluster right now I don't have any so
let's start with deploying the very
first one I clicked on that deploy from
marketplace button which actually opened
up the catalog of applications available
for for kubernetes clusters so I just
want to call out here is what we we're
pretty deeply integrated from a
marketplace perspective into GCP
services so you saw where Kamel didn't
have to leave the gke UI to go find the
marketplace app that he wants to deploy
it happens right there in context
exactly so now I'm in a configuration
screen and as you can see I can select a
cluster to which my deployment will
happen and my external cluster is
already here so great now I may select a
namespace to which I will deploy that
app so I can also customize the name it
will also become the prefix for all the
resources that will be created I just
changed the size to just two replicas to
show that it is actually a cluster
but at the same time not to spend too
much time and waiting and let's hit the
deploy button what is happening we move
to the application installation screen
and we see some progress I think we are
gonna see a more detailed information
okay yeah it's here awesome so you just
deployed RabbitMQ which he procured from
the market place onto that external
cluster that he is now managing through
GK
so you mentioned kubernetes applications
kubernetes applications are a great way
of managing multiple resources that form
a single installation like RabbitMQ in
this particular case like we don't only
get the list of all the resources that
formed my rabbitmq cluster but we can
also see some additional information
like here probably a password like I
wouldn't try this right now and and a
username I could use it for logging in
so in the meantime I would just take a
quick look at the service because by
default it was private and we could see
one more feature that is currently
offered and so let's click on the edit
button and I would actually want to
change the cluster IP type of this
service to load balancer I want to make
the service available publicly so let's
hit save the other advantage with
treating you know having rabbitmq be a
kubernetes app is that UI you just saw
where we were able to pull information
from the configs and be able to show you
the secrets right there from within the
UI rather than you having to dig through
a bunch of config files that was made
possible because of the work we've done
in packaging these into a single app ok
and what you can see right now we
automatically integrate it with load
balancer working on another cloud and we
get a public and pointer that's amazing
so let's give Robert a few minutes to
actually finish the installation we can
see that one of the pods is already
being scheduled we want to have two and
in the meantime we can switch the
environment to on Prem so on Prem GK on
Prem was announced a few months ago and
probably most of you have already heard
about
hmmm have you heard about chicken Prem
who heard about chicken from great great
to see that so not many of you have
probably a chance to try it out because
this is still in alpha but we already
got a lot of feedback from our customers
and partners and it's great like people
love it I love it too
so actually here I have another project
I have two clusters one of them is Klout
and the second one is on Prem and as you
can see this presented as an external
one I can also see all the notes like if
I'd like I can click on any of them and
to check some details like metrics that
are related to that to that particular
note or all the resources that were
deployed here so this is this is fully
managed from GK ey but it is wrong
working on a separate data center on
Prem so right here we could also try to
run a deployment of another application
maybe this time something from one of
our partners so Jenkins seems to be one
of the most popular CI CD pipelines
already used in the market like its
service show that that it's the most
popular solution for open source
projects and we actually have a partner
who prepared a curated Enterprise
version of Jenkins it's cloudBees so
let's see if we can deploy cloud-based
solution to an on-prem cluster so once
again I navigated to the applications
screen I selected cloudBees I click the
configure button and once again I can
select cluster to which I will deploy
this application and so as you can see
user cluster one is is exactly the
on-prem one its marked as external I can
create a new namespace this time let's
say so this will be cloud these demo and
I can also name my application somehow
like cloudBees demo once again now we
have the two most complicated right
thing fields in this configuration form
so in this on Prem cluster that we have
we reserved a few IP addresses that can
be used for exposing a public endpoint
and by the way I already know those IP
addresses otherwise I would have to
check them out
so this is needed so we can talk to
those on-premise servers yes
exactly this is what we want to have and
since I'm not entirely sure if those are
the correct ones I have prepared a small
note here just for myself okay I've got
it
so here I will use that IP address and
it's exactly the same yeah I remember 12
so I would select this torched name and
here I'm running the deployment let's
see what happens once again we see the
progress of the installation and
something is happening let's see the
result so stressful those live demos yep
and so just to talk about RabbitMQ is an
open source application that you deploy
to a cloud that is not GCP and now
you're taking a third-party app like
cloudBees and deploying it to an on-prem
cluster exactly this is what is
happening here we can see some progress
like logger showed so maybe let's take a
look what's in the detailed information
so moment of truth and this is cloud
base this is a detailed information
about the application and we can see
that all the resources got created so
let's take a quick look at the ingress
here maybe we'll also be able to connect
to that installation and see that
beautiful wizard of Jenkins if it's
already running maybe it's not yet so
then we will need to take to give it a
give it a minute I think so it is still
being installed so in the meantime we
can take a look at rabbitmq and let's
refresh the page and see if we already
have our post our pods running okay
let's take a quick look here
so we navigate to the stateful set and
see the rabbit okay that's always live
demos so it gracefully it gracefully
failed but still gracefully failed in an
external cluster so let's take a look if
cloud this is actually here okay almost
there I think so let's take a look at
this pod and the pulp is already running
so we should be able to see Jenkins in
just a few seconds so we're expecting a
beautiful wizard that should actually
start asking me for a password that I
should take from a container and I think
something is working because I got
redirected to the login page yes that's
right but I consider yeah Bob is running
on pram great so at this point we have
already fulfilled first two steps that I
promised to show so what we did we
connected an external cluster running on
another cloud 2gk UI and in addition to
that we also show deploying deploying
the application to on Prem and to an
external cluster so at this point we
should actually switch to the code and
transfer it into a running application
so I know that Java is a bit like old
fashioned way of building applications
but I really like it this is why I use
Java the problem with Java is that you
always get a lot of code for doing
simple stuff but I actually used spring
boot and spring code is pretty simple to
to build in the race oh it's an
application development framework that's
running in Java it's extremely popular
like it allows you to take advantage of
many built-in configurations and
integrations so just to take a quick
look at what did we do here we had this
we had this architecture diagram
that was using a deployment for an API
and another deployment for the backend
so let's take a look how how it looks
like here so I have two endpoints in
more in my application this is the REST
API so I have one of them to update the
usage and this is this is actually what
our external systems will use they will
send out data here and another one to
prepare a report of usage at the same
time we also have a component that is
handling connections with RabbitMQ and
here we have listeners that are actually
taking that requests coming from coming
through RabbitMQ and handling them
gracefully so what we want to do is
transform those those source code
components into a running application so
what we'll do first is we're gonna run
cloudbuilt who has heard about cloud
built ok some of you have so what we are
going to do here is use the CIC pipeline
that's built in into GCP and you can
easily define a few steps that should be
executed by cloud built each of them is
actually running a single container you
can pass properties to that to that
cloud build let's let's just take a look
yes it's running so this is a running a
running cloud built cloud built instance
job in the first one I'm building the
API component and the second is building
actually the backend one after that my
container images will be published to
container registry that is also a
managed service offered on Google Cloud
so I not only have the way to build the
containers I also have a way to store
them here and by the way I also took
advantage of another service offered on
Google cloud this is cloud source
repositories so I didn't have to care
about building my own git repository
anywhere I already had
in google cloud so this is where this is
where my code lives so let's move
farther what can we see here is that our
applicant
containers are already being built let's
show the newest locks first I think it
will take another minute or two so in
the meantime we could take a look about
the way of transforming those container
images into an actual application
running on kubernetes so let's start
with the applications CRD that that you
mentioned previously I already have
something like this here so this is a CR
D this is a custom resource definition
that was created together with special
interest group of applications in
kubernetes and here I defined the
application name I defined some
descriptions versions and so on but most
important I defined the rules for
collecting different types of workloads
and resources already running on
kubernetes to say that they form
together an application so this is this
is what I have here and it's of course
accompanied by other manifests that that
I have so the llamo file for API I have
it here I start with a dedicated service
account and follow it with the
deployment pointing to my container
image and actually exposing a service
with an ingress all of those happening
in regular kubernetes manifests but
after that collected by the application
so let's let's run this this
installation in the meantime we could
just take a very quick look at the
builds yep that's done so our container
images are already now already built so
we're gonna run the application here so
as you do that just want to clarify that
the audience is following along we we
created a container image and now you
are making a make it transforming it
into a kubernetes app by packaging it
with an application resource erd yep
exactly
we'll start with actually
running running the cubicle comment to
deploy everything so all of our
manifests will be automatically
automatically installed to our another
cluster I'm using a proxy machine
because the on-prem cluster is actually
located in external data set data center
and that data center does not have
public connectivity by default only
through those three IP addresses and
it's on the external it's and summary
egress so what I'm going to do right now
is combine two steps I will and I will
reach our manifests with sidecar proxies
with sidecar proxies for Sto and at the
same time I will apply the manifests to
that kubernetes cluster that we have
sam'l can you say more about why we're
entering use using a sto sidecar sure so
we wanted to use easier for additional
security and easier is easily taking
care of all the network traffic
management how it does it is actually
built on top of Android so we put those
additional containers of envoi as a
sidecar to each pod running our
application and thanks to that all the
network traffic is going through those
proxies inside pods this is one of the
one of the most basic easier features
and thanks to that easier is going to
take care of all the traffic here so
let's take a look if our application got
already deployed so I navigate to the
list of applications and yes it's here
it's kubernetes app and it says that
some components are still being
installed but we can take a look what is
already here ok we have two deployments
we have services actually one service
and an ingress we have a config map and
the secret that's great so let's open
that ingress it's saying that it's still
being configured but I think it might be
already available so I click on it and I
see a beautiful swagger UI by the way
are you already using swagger
please raise your hand yeah almost
everyone is harder so swagger is a way
of defining the documentation or
actually the standard of your API and it
can be easily used in an API gateway
like a PG transform your swagger
configuration to running an API so I
have two endpoints here let's see if
they work so I will start with sending a
query for Earth for a report so let's
say that I want a report for the whole
year this nice swagger
UI is actually allowing me to send REST
API calls to my endpoints yes I have a
report so let's see if it's also running
for updates this is what our external
systems will do so I will send an update
for the same resource I will specify
some some date here for the last year
let's say in the first of January we're
getting very close to your 25 minutes
okay I know I know but we're almost done
okay
and we're actually confirming that
everything is working like which is
which is a big part of the demo don't
complain that much come on
so let's take a look here the previous
report was having some huge number but
we want to actually increase it it ends
with 8 it should end with 0 after the
update let's try it out ok everything
couldn't find so the message was
scheduled to the broker and let's see if
it was actually handled yeah it was yeah
awesome ok so we have our application
working so just one small thing that we
could do like in this report you can see
that the overview is to do so to do is
suggesting that we are not dining at so
let's make it done so let's take a look
where it might be it might be in the
broker controller if I remember well
because this is what I did so we want
that to be done so let's change to do to
done and now let the magic happen
and we'll commit that change so it and
get comet and get comet get comment once
again and that comet will say that and
send it out okay
so I send out a new comet to my
repository and I also added attack here
and now there is a piece of magic that I
wanted to show you so there is cloud
built and in that cloud built actually
two new bills were already triggered
thanks to that comet why because I have
a trigger that is saying actually I have
two different triggers that is that both
of which are saying that whenever a new
change is happening to my repository and
there is a new tag it's automatically
building container images and if I'd
like I can add additional step to
actually running a rolling update on my
on my deployments and and this is a
great approach I think to releasing new
builds like everything that you should
care about is actually the source code
and whenever you're delivering an update
to your code it should be automatically
picked up by your CI CD pipeline and
deliver to different environments like
there's no point to doing in doing any
manual work here okay so you say that we
are running out of time so maybe let's
not wait for the tablet to happen it
will build out new container images and
this new release can be can be can be
used in our deployments but there is one
more thing that I wanted to show you so
we wanted to have SEO here so let's say
if my SEO connection is still working
now so I will just I'll just run a port
forward to make it happen so or forward
for AoE you know on port 8080 to what
are you doing here I'm just running a
port forward so I want to I want to
forward the port of my east
visualization tool key ally from UM from
cluster to my local computer and let's
see if it's working so
[Music]
almost there are not entirely there
might also happen I love those live
demos let's just establish the
connection once again and here I'm
connecting to the first proxy after that
to a second the security so just a
second and another connection with port
forwarding and after that just one more
port forward port forwards and okay
there is already something listening so
PS scrap forward and kill kill the
previous forward and let's do it again
forward forward yep something is running
what's seen oh yeah it worked I love it
so just one thing that I wanted to show
you is this is the service mesh that was
automatically created by ezo so thanks
to that proxy sidecars that we had in
our deployments east EO was actually
able to build the whole service -
visualization and we also have a small
small addition to that so pause trance
and East yo configuration so what I
wanted to show here is basically a kind
of securing your infrastructure with
East Y so but just by defining
additional service roles for accessing
the specific services in our governance
cluster and binding those roles to
specific service accounts or users we
can define who can connect to a
particular end point like in this case
we define who is able to connect to our
Postgres instance tastic so you got
through yeah that's all everything are
you satisfied I'm more than satisfied
what would have taken us
is just took us minutes you know that's
amazing awesome thank you so what we saw
in the demo is the ability to connect
deploy create improve and secure and
you've you've seen us how you know how
we could use the gke UI and the GCP
marketplace to really light that up so
thanks coming for walking us through
those very very detailed steps we also
wanted to just wrap up here with showing
you how the strategy of being able to go
after hybrid and on-prem is really
attracting large enterprises to use GCP
marketplace and we're hoping that you
will also be one of them very soon if
you're not already using it we're also
seeing that you know we're announcing
these open source service partners which
you may have seen at the keynote as well
but these are really going to help us
deliver really popular open source
solutions to our customers through the
marketplace and we believe that this
will show our deepened commitment
towards open source as well finally just
want to announce our newest kubernetes
Absolution palo alto networks that just
announced their service smash security
adapter using sto and is available in
the marketplace today and we're very
excited because this is an example of a
partner that started with VMs and a sort
of expanding their portfolio to cover
kubernetes apps and other types of
solutions within the marketplace we're
also welcoming a number of new and
updated listings and calling out updated
because it shows you just how engaged
our partners are with the marketplace so
you can find new apps there every day as
well as new features to existing apps
that you can use you can see a list here
of brand new exciting startups as well
as very established companies and if you
you know you've seen the power of the
GCP marketplace if you're a partner or a
developer that wants to sell on the
marketplace and really increase your
reach please go to cloud.google.com
slash marketplace that slash sell and we
can talk you through about you know
there's an entire process and how we can
get you through the marketplace and
really help you expand your reach so
today just to recap we covered the waste
kubernetes app scan
improve the developer experience for
cloud native projects we did a demo with
some you know real-time anxiety in it of
building an app from scratch on anthos
our new hybrid and multi cloud platform
but camel showed you just how easy it is
to be able to go from no really nothing
to being able to have a fully deployed
app not just on Prem but in the hybrids
not just hybrid but in multi cloud
scenarios and we showed you how the GCP
marketplace is integrated into your
experience and supports and offers open
source as well as commercial solutions
that accelerate your development to
calls for action
one is if you haven't visited our GCP
marketplace showcase yet please go see
the demo there and you can visit us
online at cloud or google.com slash
kubernetes - applications thank you
[Music]
you